hi i'm ben platt hi i'm amanda stenberg
and this is the wired autocomplete
interview
where oh wow i'm gone i can't work like
this actually
what ben platt
what did ben platt
win a tony for
i won a tony for this musical called
dear evan hansen
i don't know if you've heard of it or if
you've heard me talking about it in the
last seven to six years that's what i
won my 24. and my whole family was there
it was very special
dream come true what is ben platt's
phone number that's gonna be a pass from
me in terms of sharing in terms of
sharing my phone number i will say
that i posted a picture of my dog of
george and it had my family's phone
number on his collar just in case he
like ever ran away and the story was up
for like three minutes and then my
friend text me just like do you realize
that like you just gave your family's
phone number to the world and so i
really freaked out but thankfully
everybody online listened and stopped
calling so thank you
that's kind yeah it's probably because
you have like theater kids as fans and
they're pretty nice yeah yeah until you
try to change a musical that they love
and then they come for you yeah
what
type of dog does ben platt
have
drum roll
uh i have a labradoodle and his name is
george
georgie platt i named him for george
serrat which is a real life artist a
portalist artist but also the main
character of my favorite musical sunday
in the park with george i have a big
poster in my house of sunday the park
with george i named him that a because
it's my favorite musical and b because
when he was a puppy he had these little
dots on his nose
and so
that's why he's george but they're gone
now because he's a big boy
what
does ben platt
sang in the politician
oh season two
that was the twist
the twist of season two well in season
one i sang river by joni mitchell and a
song from assassins which is a musical
it's stephen sondheim wrote and i think
it was zoe deutsch hi zoe
season two oh season two i saying corner
of the sky from pippin which is another
fave musical and it was also my senior
high school role in my high school
musical which was pippin and i played
pippin it's so very full circle and i
got to sing my song run away from my
first album sync to me instead on the
politician as well because it was free
to use
and
and it's a good song thanks hey thanks
maybe someday someone let me sing for my
second album reverie which you can get
now
throw that thing f out of here
how am endless denberg how am endless
number how
is amandla steinberg
i love that that's one of the first
questions how is people want to know how
you are amandla stenbergs uh pretty
great yeah i would say yeah living in
new york city
i have a home for the first time in many
years after bouncing around
just came back from copenhagen visiting
my dad rob
i'm doing i'm doing pretty good guys
how nice is that to here how did amandla
stenberg
become an actress
how did i become an actress
i started acting when i was
about three or four because i wanted to
be in commercials pretty late on tv
late in the game
yeah and then the first movie role that
i booked was when i was 11
or no eight
nine wait i just jumped around so much i
was i was nine i was nine and i played
the younger version of zoe saldana as an
assassin
wow
so pretty cool from the gecko
how old was amandla stenberg
in the hunger
games
i was 12. wow
i remember you i played rue in the
hunger games
duh the baby roo has anyone not seen
hunger again
i was such a huge fan
that i wouldn't leave their casting
people alone because i heard they were
making a movie and so i think i would
call like every single day
and then i got
an audition i remember i got a call back
and the casting director deborah zane
she really like was rooting for me so
i'm
perpetually grateful
to her
but she told me okay when you come back
for the call back
make sure that you are dressed in
character
because she knew this would kind of like
help me really prove to them like what i
would be like in the world of film and
some
i fully dressed up i think i had like a
little cargo pants on and you know the
utilitarian vibe okay
and going for it running it and i
remember rolling around in the backyard
before i went so i was covered in mud
and
then when i arrived it was at gary
ross's house
and he had like all like cream suede
furniture
and i remember just like shuffling
through his living room you know like
with all the other actresses there and
everything i think eventually i like
grabbed a stool from outside and just
like sat in the corner because i was
really nervous i was gonna ruin his
couch but instead you booked it but i
got the job baby because she went all in
you guys
show up covered in dirt for your next
audition exactly
how
tall is a manless stenberg
to be specific i guess that means like
only americans are curious about how
tall i am yeah nobody else cares right
well americans i'm five feet tall and
three inches
which is a fourth of a foot
is ben plata
the astronaut on the mess singer
no sadly i'm not the astronaut on the
mat singer nor have i ever seen or been
on the mass singer but no shade to the
mass singer
you should go on the math singer
i think i'm good
i like to sing with my face showing if i
were to go on the mass singer i would
probably just do it in drag
so yeah
is ben platt
the baby and father of the bride too
yes yes wait you are well i wasn't in
actually in front of the bride too but
we did a little father the bride three
like short film that nancy meyers made
during the pandemic and florence pew and
i played the babies grown up
so technically yes i am the baby and
part of the bride too
so is ben platt on cameo i am not on
cameo sadly however if you want to chill
or meet you can come to see my concert
and i can see you from the audience
slash you could also sign up to do a
meet and greet and we could meet that
way so what the heck is cameo it's like
a website where people can pay you to
like make them video messages like i got
noah for for
like i don't even know what the occasion
maybe his birthday
for uh i got her megan's alter like
talking to him in a costume via cameo hi
max dalton are you the best
okay there's a lot of fun people on
there wow
is ben platt a libra i actually don't
know your son i am a libra i'm just past
the cusp but i'm i'm a libra i'm very
like
very much the mediator very much like
middle of the road i feel that even
killed thank you yeah i'm a libra
scorpio
i'm right on the cusp when's your
birthday october 23rd
so i feel the libra
synergy between us
i'm definitely
probably a little crazier than you
i'll let you have that
whereas i'm more neurotic
right
is ben platt nice
no
so mean really cool look at this face
such a mean
cruel face
see
a manless denver just in general yeah
what's up why was the bandless spendberg
name amandla
wow i was named amandla because amandla
or how it's actually pronounced amantla
amantla
means power in zulu and hosa and during
apartheid in south african it was a very
popular rallying cry a mantle away to
which means power to the people amazing
and my mom was like i'mma give my baby
a name that means something i love it
you're the only amandla that i know
why is amanda stenberg a role model
i don't know
why i was playing my own she's unique
queer
talented confident gorgeous never before
seen unlike anything you've ever seen in
your life whatever that lady got chew it
up put it in a blender spit it out
is it manly steinberg vegan
no
i love that that's like a question that
people have
never in my life could i be vegan you
love me
it's not even that i love meat i don't i
don't have the maturity in terms of my
eating habits to ensure i would be
getting all the nutrients and vitamins
that i would need if i was vegan
absolutely absolutely also i love
burgers amandla stenberg fun facts don't
you just have like 10 fun facts about
yourself ready to go at all times
fun fact fun fact when i was younger
i used to
voice over people's voices and movies
because i like i
was good at
watching the adr on screen and figuring
out the rhythm of how people were
speaking and then replicating it do you
know like if i went back and like
watched one of them where i would find
your voice
why did i get married too
guys
but i always felt kind of bad because i
was like damn some actress is gonna go
see the movie
and it's gonna be my voice well if it's
good adr they probably can't tell what
does that does
does that mean you could also win a lip
sync for your life you think
yes okay it's actually my dream to lip
sync for my life mine too i'm endless
denver violin
violin
yes i play the violin
what
i don't think i knew that you didn't
know that that's sick yeah i play the
violin i used to be a part of a folk
band embarrassing oh i thought i didn't
know and i still play the violin but now
i don't play folk music i
kind of play random weird i don't know
punky-ish sort of stuff so you're gonna
play at the premiere gonna do a
performance never in my life would i do
that
how high
can ben platt
sing
wow
do you know the note you can think
through
you must well i don't know how high i
can sing like period i would say like in
a chest voice which means like full
voice belted on a great day i can sing
like a c or a c sharp but on like a any
given day probably like b flat
so for anyone that cares to know that
giving us that half step d2
where oh wow i'm gone i can't work like
this actually
i'm so sorry i'm sorry
this is actually really painful
cardboard so sorry i feel bad the edges
are really sharp
where did ben black go to summer camp
well i went to camp roman california in
ojai which is a jewish summer camp which
is basically like a regular summer camp
except like you were kippahs which is
like the little jewish hats and you like
do prayers sometimes
but the highlight of my camp experience
was color wars which is where the whole
camp is divided into four teams of like
100 kids each and then you fight in like
sports competitions but more importantly
in giant cheers and skits
and so when i was the captain of the red
team priority we had gorgeous
productions for every one of our cheers
and we did win so why did ben platt
leave dear evan hansen
well i had been working on the show for
like three four years i did
all the readings all the workshops i did
the washington dc production the
off-broadway second stage production and
then i did the broadway production for a
year and it was wonderful fulfilling
beautiful experience but very taxing
physically emotionally mentally all that
stuff and just not super sustainable to
continue to do eight times a week longer
than that so i really wanted to leave
while i still was standing and was still
being uh be able to give a full
performance and before i you know wear
myself out too hard but then i got to
come back and do the movie
very lucky yes you did
can i lean on you ben platt yeah
you can
any time
[Music]
the most important card of all dear evan
hansen dear evan hansen we've been way
too out of touch okay
is dear evan hansen a musical what do
you think yes
hardcore a lot of songs great songs
pascal paul songs and one pasik and paul
stenberg song
is dear evan hansen fiction or
non-fiction
i feel like there are many non-fiction
elements of it totally there's a lot of
yes there's a fictional story it is it
is totally fictional in terms of the
story but inspired by a lot of
contemporary truths that are non-fiction
but
fiction there's no evan hansen except
for the character
who wrote dear evan hansen music paskin
paul wrote it brilliant songwriters who
also wrote the musical dogfight the
songs in la la land greatest showman and
then there's one new song that amandla
wrote with them
what is the message of dear evan hansen
there's a lot of messages
well i think there's different messages
for for different people what's your
fave message my fave message
is that
contending with mental health is a
universal
experience and something that
so many more of us than you would maybe
assume are dealing with and going
through and it's okay to not be okay you
have value as a human being regardless
of
if you're at a high high or at a low low
and you are deserving of love
that's beautiful and i agree
what did the dear evan hansen let her
say well there's several letters
throughout the film right but the kind
of hero letter
is
dear evan hansen today is going to be a
good day and here's why because all you
have to do is just be yourself
and usually it ends with sincerely me
which is also the name of one of the
songs
in the movie
i feel like i learned a lot about you i
learned what amandla means
i learned that you play violin i learned
that you were the baby and uh father of
the bride and father of the right oh no
but you did that with florence pugh
mm-hmm you gotta check that out
i think i actually knew a lot of other
stuff about you thanks so much
[Music]